cuándo
un juicio político contra el presidente
sebastián piñera intenta destituir la
oposición presentó en la cámara de
diputados- una acusación constitucional
en su contra tras las revelaciones de
los papeles de pandora hablamos con uno
de los diputados que firmó la acusación
contra el mandatario el mayor puerto del
reino unido- está bloqueado miles de
contenedores se quedaron atascados y la
falta de suministros amenaza la cantidad
de productos para navidad las navieras
comenzaron a redirigir los barcos a
otros países para luego intentar
transportarlos a suelo británico y rusia
dice que no utiliza el gas como arma
geopolítica así el presidente vladimir
putin respondió a los señalamientos
contra el kremlin en que las lo acusan
de retener las reservas para presionar
el gasoducto nord stream 2 por el mar
báltico
bienvenidos a esta nueva emisión
informativa de france 24 yo soy maría y
arkaitz comencemos en chile porque la
oposición inició un proceso para
intentar destituir al presidente
sebastián piñera la cámara de diputados
analiza una acusación constitucional por
su aparición en los papeles de pandora
al mandatario se le acusa de evadir
impuestos y beneficiarse económicamente
a expensas de la venta de la minera
dominga a pesar de que estaba cerca de
una reserva ambiental alva santana nos
explica qué está ocurriendo
más problemas para el presidente
sebastián piñera ahora de la mano de la
oposición chilena que presentó ante la
cámara de diputados- una acusación para
iniciar un juicio político en su contra
para destituirlo del cargo por su
implicación en los papeles de pandora es
absolutamente inaceptable que un
presidente de la república esté
utilizando su cargo para negocios
personales para favorecer a su familia
realizando operaciones en paraísos
fiscales todos los antecedentes de esta
acusación
permiten decir que va a haber un apoyo
mayoritario hace una semana la
investigación situó a piñera como uno de
los tres dirigentes en activo de américa
latina' señalados en los papeles en
estos se le acusaba por la participación
en la venta en 2010 de la minera dominga
que se hizo sin que el presidente
declarara la protección ambiental a
pesar de que la mina está cerca de una
reserva de pingüinos algo que el
mandatario negó rotundamente
los antecedentes estaba
incluyendo su precio forma de pago y
condiciones fueron conocidas por la
fiscalía por el tribunal de garantía y
por la corte de apelaciones
todos ellos determinaron en forma
consistente y unánime la inexistencia de
delitos y la inocencia de mi persona
pero la fiscalía nacional también cree
que hay pruebas en contra de piñera por
lo que hace cinco días comenzó una
investigación en su contra algo que se
suma el descontento del pueblo desde la
filtración de los archivos
a la renuncia a una situación delicada
para el líder chileno cuyo futuro está
ahora en manos de la cámara de
diputados- y la fiscalía y precisamente
mientras se define el futuro político de
sebastián piñera el presidente sostiene
que el intento de destitución sólo tiene
un fin electoral y no hay argumentos
jurídicos para ello según el mandatario
a propósito del tema conversamos
previamente con gonzalo winter el ex
diputado del partido convergencia social
y uno de los congresistas que firma la
acusación él nos explicó que podría
venir para el mandatario
yo creo que esto en la cámara diputado
se va a probar pero en el senado
necesita dos tercios de los votos
obviamente puede ser muy difícil de
conseguir dependiendo los antecedentes
que se vayan verificando y de la forma
en que los senadores los aprecien y con
respecto a las elecciones quiero ser muy
claro
no es no es grato acusar al presidente
la república a mí no me gusta que se les
presente la república me gusta la idea
que los presente la república terminen
su mandato nunca en nuestros 200 años de
historia republicana se ha destituido
legalmente como presidente sin embargo
el nivel de rabia que hay en la sociedad
chilena por la sensación de impunidad
frente a un grupo de empresarios que ha
controlado la totalidad de las
decisiones económicas y políticas del
país durante más de tres décadas es tan
grande que mi impresión es que
independiente de que para las elecciones
presidenciales a mi sector no le
conviene esta acusación porque en mi
sector en el que según la encuesta va
ganando las elecciones creo que para la
estabilidad del país y para recomponer
la
la acción del pueblo con las
instituciones es necesario que se haga
justicia
vayamos ahora a europa porque en reino
unido- la escasez de camioneros sigue
causando estragos la falta de
suministros amenaza la navidad pues
también faltan juguetes ropa y otros
productos importados todo por el bloqueo
en el mayor puerto comercial del país
donde miles de contenedores están
atascados la gigante naviera danesa
maersk por ejemplo está redirigiendo sus
barcos más grandes a los puertos de
países bajos y de bélgica para
descargarlos allí y luego enviarlos a la
isla en naves más pequeñas marinas
ardilla nos cuenta la historia
la crisis en la cadena de suministro
podría dejar a miles de británicos sin
regalos de navidad unos 50.000
contenedores están bloqueados en el
mayor puerto comercial de reino unido
felixstowe que maneja alrededor del 40%
de las cargas de mercancías que entran y
salen de la isla
creo que habrá algunos transtornos de
estas navidades como resultado de la
escasez de camiones pero los minoristas
son realmente expertos en asegurarse de
que dan prioridad a las cosas que la
gente quiere
a poco menos de dos meses de las
festividades navideñas el periodo más
activo para las empresas navieras y
puertos los retrasos en las entregas a
las tiendas de productos importados son
evidentes en reino unido donde el 90% de
las importaciones llegan por mar las
causas del congestionamiento portuario
son múltiples el break sheet la pandemia
y la falta de conductores de vehículos
pesados que han obligado a desviar
grandes buques a puertos de países
vecinos
hay un enorme retraso en las entregas
creadas por la escasez de conductores el
break sheet y una serie de otras cosas
que acaban de crear la tormenta perfecta
sin embargo el co presidente del partido
conservador gobernante a los británicos
a comprar con normalidad
es evidente que existe un problema sobre
todo con los conductores de vehículos
pesados y no sólo aquí sino en toda
europa polonia eeuu e incluso china por
eso hemos tomado medidas para
solucionarlo por ejemplo más formación
5000 plazas más para la formación de
conductores de vehículos pesados
flexibilizando el proceso estamos
trabajando en estos desafíos
sánchez reino unido tiene una escasez de
unos 100.000 camioneros que obligó a las
autoridades a ofrecer cinco mil visados
temporales para trabajadores extranjeros
además de la congestión en los puertos
reino unido- tiene su mirada puesta en
otro tema la comisión europea presentó
hoy un paquete de medidas para tratar de
resolver los problemas con la aplicación
del protocolo del break si está en la
frontera con irlanda del norte es el
intento de convencer a reino unido que
cumpla lo pactado por su parte del
gobierno británico exigió al bloque un
nuevo protocolo porque afirma que el
actual no funciona nuestra corresponsal
en bruselas esther herrera nos explicó
previamente la propuesta del bloque al
gobierno de boris johnson con respecto a
irlanda del norte
es para evitar los problemas que ha
habido en los últimos meses en irlanda
del norte que recordemos desde el break
sheet está en el mercado único europeo
para evitar nada y para evitar una
frontera física con la república de
irlanda bruselas ha propuesto reducir
los controles aduaneros que actualmente
se producen entre reino unido e irlanda
del norte así la comisión europea
propone un 80 por ciento de reducción de
los controles aduaneros en bienes como
por ejemplo los productos cárnicos como
las salchichas tan importantes en los
desayunos de tantos británicos pero que
hubo problemas en los supermercados
antes del verano porque a causa de estos
controles las salchichas no llegaba
también se facilitará la importación de
medicamentos a irlanda del norte-
provenientes del reino unido- jesse
evitar cualquier tipo de disolución y
problemas en la cadena de suministro en
definitiva se trata de reducir todo tipo
de controles al máximo para así evitar
que el anda del norte tenga la sensación
de que está al margen del reino unido
pero nada se trata de reabrir el
protocolo de irlanda del norte porque
provocaría grandes problemas así que por
el momento bruselas
ignora a londres y sus amenazas de una
guerra comercial y sigamos hablando de
fronteras pero ahora vamos a eeuu porque
el país volverá a abrir sus cruces
dentro de un mes para los transportes
terrestres desde y hacia méxico y canadá
el cruce estuvo prohibido durante 19
meses a causa de la pandemia el
requisito es tener el esquema completo
de vacunación contra el coronavirus se
espera que también haya una
flexibilización similar para los viajes
aéreos en noviembre méxico y canadá
presionaron durante meses a la casa
blanca para que permitiera el tránsito
por eso ahora el gobierno de andrés
manuel lópez obrador celebró la decisión
él me confirmó el centro de mallorca
ayer por la noche que a partir de los
primeros días de noviembre ellos van a
determinar la fecha exacta la daremos a
conocer en cuanto la conozcamos
iniciando noviembre se van a reanudar
las actividades quiere decir esto se van
a permitir los viajes
terrestres y aéreos a eeuu para las
personas que están vacunadas el huracán
para vela tocó tierra en el estado
mexicano de sinaloa convertido en
categoría 1 luego se degradó a tormenta
tropical la comisión federal de
electricidad de méxico estima que cerca
de 120 mil usuarios se quedaron sin luz
en sinaloa y en nayarit por su parte del
gobernador sinaloense quirino ordaz
advirtió que podría haber inundaciones y
deslizamientos por el paso de pamela el
centro nacional de huracanes de eeuu
estima que el fenómeno se debilitará
todavía más y que creará marejadas en
algunas costas de méxico y en el sur de
la península de baja california
y hablemos ahora de un tema económico la
inflación de eeuu aumentó en septiembre
más de lo previsto y esto lo sienten
directamente los consumidores los
estadounidenses pagaron más por
alimentos alquiler y otra clase de
bienes todo porque los precios al
consumidor subieron un 0,4 por ciento y
el aumento puede no parar ahí pues se
estima que en los próximos meses sea
todavía más alto por el incremento de
los costos de productos energéticos
muchos dudan de que la alta inflación
que trazó la reserva federal no sea
transitoria como lo planteó en un inicio
ponerle un límite a la sal que consumen
los estadounidenses esa es la nueva meta
de la administración de drogas y
alimentos fda que está presionando para
reducir los niveles de sodio en los
alimentos procesados como carnes
envasadas y quesos las autoridades
sanitarias intentan frenar los
crecientes problemas de salud
prevenibles la de fedea quiere que cada
persona consuma como máximo un promedio
de 3000 miligramos cada día estos 400
miligramos menos que el promedio actual
y todavía están lejos del límite
recomendado de 2.300 miligramos
el presidente ruso vladimir putin
rechazó los señalamientos de que su
gobierno utiliza el gas como un arma
geopolítica mientras que europa afronta
una creciente crisis energética de cara
a la llegada del invierno en el
hemisferio norte putin negó que
estuviera recibiendo reservas para
presionar a sus consumidores y promover
así el desarrollo del gasoducto nord
stream 2 por el mar báltico les contamos
más en este reporte
en un foro energético en moscú vladimir
putin aseguró que rusia está dispuesta a
suministrar más gas a europa si bruselas
lo pide y negó que el kremlin usará el
gas como una arma política juego derecha
también
recibe las acusaciones de que rusia usa
la energía como un arma no tienen
sentido
es basura políticamente motivada si nos
piden aumentar los suministros estamos
dispuestos a hacer los widgets pastel
los hay excluye críticos aseguran que el
kremlin está limitando las exportaciones
de gas con el objetivo de presionar para
la aprobación del nuevo gaseoducto north
stream 2 a través del mar báltico hacia
alemania el recorrido del nuevo
gaseoducto esquivaría ucrania aliado
clave de la unión europea quien dejaría
de cobrar impuestos de tránsito y su
propio suministro de gas se vería
afectado los gaseoductos rusos aportan
más de un tercio de las importaciones
europeas los principales clientes
europeos confirman que rusia cumple con
sus compromisos sin embargo los precios
han aumentado cerca del 600 por ciento y
se espera que lo peor esté por llegar
putin asegura que el problema recae en
el mercado europeo y que bruselas no
debería echar la cuerda a moscú
a lo largo de la pasada década poco a
poco errores sistemáticos han ido
afectando al sector energético europeo
son ellos quienes han provocado una
crisis a gran escala en el mercado
europeo rincón libre putin también
prometió que encaminaría a rusia hacia
el objetivo de la neutralidad de
emisiones de co2 para 2060 como tarde la
promesa coincide con la alerta de la
agencia internacional de energía que
asegura que deben triplicarse las
inversiones en energías verdes para
alcanzar la reducción de emisiones
establecida por la onu para 2030
y una australiana se convirtió en la
persona que más veces ha cruzado el
canal de la mancha nadando ella es club
y mcardle quien completó su travesía
número 44 a pesar de que tenía una
infección en el pecho se atrevió a la
nueva aventura salió en la noche del
martes desde la playa de dover en
inglaterra y después de varias horas de
nadar sin parar tocó tierra en guys and
beach en francia luego volvió a su bote
para celebrar este nuevo récord
y ahora vamos a hacer un repaso de lo
que tenemos en nuestra pagina france24
puntocom ellos también están viviendo
con los papeles de pandora y el
presidente sebastián piñera y también
está el papá francisco que admitió los
errores que cometió la iglesia católica
durante la evangelización en américa y
también está el vuelo espacial de la
empresa blue origin
y ustedes continúen con más en france24
[Música]